foreign
the holidays are coming up look look who
I'm doing it look at that the way I'm
holding it just dangling like that but I
also got a nice fat one right there
originalgrain.com Lifeline dude I love
watches with a nice weight with a nice
heftiness makes me feel like a man use
code Lifeline for a total of 30 off they
are currently running a 20 off Black
Friday deal right now but using my link
and code will give you an extra 10 off
so that makes it a total of what 10 plus
20. that's 30. I knew it that's the
highest markdown you're gonna get for
the holidays uh it's you know it's rare
it's rugged burl wood check it out
there's a larger face watch Yep this
one's a little less heavy than this one
but depends what you like comes with a
stopwatch Timing System and calendar
date function I mean it's crazy
that's the back of the watch to be
engraved it's actually really cool for
like weddings and stuff personalized
message Christmas and look holiday is
coming up you got to get gifts who
wouldn't want that also it's nice in
this personal Forum right you go yo love
you honey yo love you honey engrave it
and they get the burl wood heftiness
right on the wrist like that Rings also
the sun that's are back in stock what
these sunglasses they're back in stock
now I look crazy badass in them you
could look crazy about it yeah you could
you know be very sexy in them not just
me they're back in stock they sold out
after the last ads and we have to talk
about it again because they re-upped
they're back so all you got to do
is use the code Lifeline at
originalgrain.com
Lifeline to get 30 off and that's
site-wide whoa thirty percent off
site-wide originalgrand.com baby check
out it could be silly too not even just
sexy but silly so silly and sexy
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
let's put it on program because I know
what that means and then we'll put on
program because I know what that means
and then we'll get it to the thing okay
great let's do it
here we go we're going
we're doing it live do it live no
swearing no swearing for the first few
minutes
point at me but no swearing for the
first few minutes because you know why I
do know why but don't
point at me that's like my thing don't
push me I'm wearing the merch and get a
chrysalia.com anyway she's like not just
that's never will I ease up so stop okay
man you know that's Dub C and it's so
horrible uh you know you tell me on it
stop seeing you definitely don't need to
tell them in Step C because I do such a
sick impression that they know exactly
what it is
okay oh yeah I honestly listeners
probably don't even know who dubs he is
it's true I mean a lot of you are the
one you are the one who does this baby
you are the one you are the one you are
the one
that was sick well maybe they know he
was one of the guys in West Side
connection it was Ice Cube Dub C and Mac
10. Mark 10 dude mactan just a gun you
know yeah dude yeah I did machine gun
just actually machine actual gun you
know Glock so dumb to have that name gun
a guy yeah gun would be good uh yeah so
anyway I'm changing my name to gun okay
I'm gundalia gundalia yeah
Gondolier
what are those Italian boats yeah yeah
um yeah so uh well look man you know
it's it's great times are great and it's
all good
life's
unraveling I will be in Lakeland Florida
I will be in pull it up pull up pull up
pull up pull up up up I'll be in
Lakeland Florida Jacksonville Florida I
will be in Seattle Portland Oregon I
will be in New York I will be in uh San
Diego or his mom would say San Diego I
will be in San Antonio I will be in
Sugarland Texas New Orleans Providence
Rhode Island I already said that one
Chicago Kansas City Springfield Tulsa
Austin there's so many just go to
chrysler.com get your tickets I'm on
tour my babies I am on tour my babies
and I make great Christmas gifts I'm
gonna throw my babies it's Christmas go
pick up your alert go pick your uh
Christmas go pick up your stuff if you
got Lifeline fans uh lifelinemirch.com
got it right
congrats or you guys I'm not being a
dumbo for once in your life uh good
knock swearing if you got a question
click the link in the description below
or go to watch lifeline.com or if you
want one-on-one advice sessions with
Matt
then just go to matalia.com
mattdelia.com
Tuesdays and Thursdays 1 35 30 Pacific
time and let me ask you a question Chris
okay you haven't ever told me this okay
but I guarantee I know it's true
doesn't it piss you off when I specify
what times I'm available on Tuesdays and
Thursdays it doesn't piss me off but why
do you do that
oh I'll tell you why I don't understand
first off is why it pisses you off it
doesn't really piss me off a little bit
though no it doesn't piss me off not
even a little bit but but why though
because people
it's really just to get to the Pacific
time part people don't look at the time
zone and think it's they think it's
their time understood yeah which is very
self-centered thing to think and so we
got a lot to talk about especially since
they probably know you're on the if you
think about it you're on the Pacific
absolutely everybody knows where I'm at
my
oops my effing uh children I'm sorry I
already blew it all my children now
um
yeah well you know you're you're Pacific
so we're Pacific baby Pacific time when
you book it's Pacific time you even have
a purple phone case
so I mean blending into your shirt might
as well put in the center there so we
can see it on the screen
I mean QVC QVC we have got a beautiful
purple case let me just show the metal
show it to you here look it's absolutely
gorgeous isn't it hold it a little bit
so it more reflected away for there we
go oh now I get why they do that because
anyway movies around look at that now
you've got grease stains in the middle
that's from his thumb okay no it's on my
fingers that's from your fingers right
there it's absolutely beautiful look at
that the way you type it you can type on
that that way you can type on the other
way you know but it is absolutely
gorgeous it is coming right now if you
buy one purple case you will get a
purple velor shirt you will get this as
supplies last we only have how many do
we have Phil
he's saying we only have a hundred left
we're gonna dock it down we want them to
fly but they're honestly they're going a
little too quick so we're gonna dock
them down we're gonna make them you can
get now you can get these you can get
another version of this
you can get another version of this for
probably a hundred and ten dollars this
is a better version
and we are not gonna give it to you for
a hundred dollars [ __ ] screaming dude
just absolutely outright screaming
here's here's the thing if you want this
for 100 you go to them right Phil you
can go to well we can't say the
competitors names but you go we are not
going to give it to you for a hundred
dollars we are not going to give it to
you for ninety dollars we are not going
to give it to you for eighty dollars
what we are not going to give it to you
today right now for seventy dollars
we are not going to give it to you for
sixty dollars
we could give it to you for fifty
dollars but I'm feeling generous we are
not going to give it three minutes
we are not going to give it to you for
forty dollars or thirty dollars today
only today while supplies last and I
don't know like Phil's telling me not to
do it we are going to give it to you for
four
payments
of 12 cents
and they're gone they're gone just like
that two purple faces so long to get to
the end yeah with the purple velor shirt
also he's you have been doing you yeah
how could you say who when I say you
pointing at you yeah I thought you're
talking about me he I'm like he who he
is me laughing you wow wow [ __ ] wow
he who he who you okay uh so you've been
doing that yeah for can't even tell you
how long 23 years can't even tell you
how long probably 23 or something like
that more maybe 25 years we've got I
would just pick up stuff around the
house look at these glasses okay we've
got and we've got Reese we have these we
and we're gonna get we're gonna give
them where we can't give them we're
gonna practically give them away
to uh yeah you can get this green wall
right now
40 easy payments of two cents well
this is not even worth it you know
that's 80 cents
say postage would cost way more yeah
posts comes away more honestly
uh so you can check on postage what else
yeah so that's what's up QVC we're
having a good time though right yeah uh
I hate it Reese's
fast break candy bar what's that and
I'll tell you why it pisses me off yeah
I'm I'm already pissed frankly
oh yeah what's this
that's a Reese's sure isn't it yeah
oh no
oh no Reese's Fast Break the green in it
it's blue it's fine but it's just like
so artificial do do do what you do
already yeah what's with the fast break
thing you know companies always think
new is best it is not you might get a
little bump at the very beginning but if
a thing sucks a thing sucks plus people
want what they traditionally
it's probably when it comes to Chocolate
yeah they like what they like already
dude like if they're gonna buy a Reese's
they're not gonna buy the new Reese's
flavor they're gonna buy a Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup baby baby
Matt you know yo what we have to do is
honestly
with the Reese's
yeah
I mean Reese's is so good right Reese's
are good yes I don't like the when they
get cute with it though they had one
with a green center like the paper the
peanut butter was Green
and I was pissed was it uh St Patrick's
Day no it was like a Halloween thing it
was like it had like you know yeah
people who in it like Slimer or
something people always feel like they
want to like
change with the times and stuff and do
it like that because if you're not
growing you're dying I get it but
Reese's you've been around bro you're a
Hershey's too like what are you doing if
you want to have a new thing new flavor
start a brand new thing with a brand new
name maker for the makers of Hershey
Green chocolate bars yes thank you and
these are called greens oh wow worse
well you would get fired from that room
not not necessarily we call them
greens I actually think that would be
dope and I'll tell you why yo greens I'm
gonna leave it this I don't want you to
answer greens he leaves
um
we don't like it no don't answer now
he's like not even a higher up you know
yeah yeah yeah he's the janitor greens
okay taking them off
dude I think that uh that would be good
because you could be like these are the
real greens instead of greens that you
think you need these are the greens kids
love oh you're welcome Hershey's oh dude
cut me a check man
I mean you got to make it at the very
end got me a check man yeah oh yeah got
me a chick moms so loud why are you so
loud yeah you know it's like you know
I know but it's like that's terrible
what you're doing terrible stuff
what are you doing
just texting people no
oh
and we call them
greens
so much set up for that you know
so much did and we call them dude how
about this and we call them greens
taking so long
on a carousel
oh actually you did that for real why
don't people have fun at work dude I
swear to God no because they get fired
no but it's bullet yes that's the radio
edit wow dude it's such horse
wow and it's like I want a stroke having
a stroke
amazing dude it's such Afghan [ __ ]
because I wanna be there and happy
having fun but all my plugins won't let
me have fun stroking dude dude foreign
ly I do frankly I frankly do Jim Lee I
do just wow so Brett Lee Brett dude how
the name Brett what's worse Brett or
Brent our friend is obviously one of my
best friends fortunately Brent Morin I'm
sorry but it's Brent dude throwing that
extra n in there is just absolutely are
you doing it what are you doing what is
the worst name for a guy he just wants
to get along in the world in like a
yeah Wally you could spin cute
because all sorts of Walter that's not
that sure sure Walter's kind of cool
actually yeah like Wally I like the name
so what are you talking about then Keith
is horrible no you know what it is what
Bruce
okay
wow dude on a carousel
on an absolute Carousel oh my God Bruce
Bruce is bad but Bruce is Bruce Willis
though yeah he's the only one he's the
only one that stands on don't come out
with Bruce Wayne no no no no no he's not
a real person yeah you know oh my God
okay man all right uh well listen shall
we yeah we should start let's do it fell
asleep and woke up soon yeah wow the
first twofer hi Chris hi Matt I'm Chris
oh I'm not and we're cousins from
Toronto Ontario cool we have a bit of a
pressing issue here we've been debating
about for
ever since we've been born and we're
just wanting to get your input on this
whose name is better oh and why
I know my
wow that was good kept it short wow
those guys look at the field they have
that was beautiful I know they're best
okay I I do too it's Matthew it's not
Matt it's Matt I'll tell you why it's
not I can tell you why I know it's not
you know you think it's Chris yeah I do
why I love the name Matt why I did for
one simple reason Chris is better okay
why because Matt is a thing and it's a
noun and Chris is not no no you're not
is it it's like naming your kid table
here's why they're both like very
Catholic names I like the name Matthew a
lot but here's the thing
Christopher it's like you actually have
Christ's name in your name and that's
why and that sucks it's like being named
Jesus I'm named Matthew this is also
biblical but it's not you know I'm not
like
the central figure in in a in a in a
religious you could call it massive cult
if you wanted to organize religion that
was really what yeah but it's not like
my name is Christopher but it is though
it's Christopher it's Christopher if you
look at it on paper so you have a name
that looks like Jesus Christ's name and
that's not good and while you're getting
so upset I can't oh he's acting folks
he's acting I was misinformed he's
acting he's crying and it's a good
performance even though he's just not
moving his face in any way at all just
doing nothing wow all good that was good
for the listeners who doesn't watch it
what was the end you licked your hand
yeah because it it fell it welled up
that's me Welling it up it forms up too
much gravity gravity takes it down
pools up here Gravity again takes it
down my hand comes in to rescue it oh
wow water put it back into my system
unbelievable disgusting
I love how this takes 20 seconds before
it can go you know
but Matthew's better because it doesn't
have Christ in it and it's not and it's
because Matt is a thing that you wipe
your feet on so it's all good
it's like naming your kid you know [ __ ]
funny that we both like our own names
better yeah I think usually I think it
would normally be the case where
Brothers like one another's name is
better you know I don't like the fact
that you said that it has Christ in it
and that's the thing and that makes it
bad is not but it makes it bad why did
it make you mad I saw your face
have you have you thought that before
yeah that's why I said it well or maybe
you just thought of it right now no dude
I've thought about it before so it
pisses me off that you've you've been
holding on to that oh you've been
holding on to yours
I've told you a thing about the map
before
I did driving me
[Applause]
ah I did nope I did you know I don't
like names that are also nouns like
Chuck Rob
Matt
penis condom I mean sorry nothing penis
condom Peter's you know there's a lot of
Phil
fill her up yeah exactly uh
what else is like that you got you gave
enough examples as you have like seven
examples we don't need much more I know
there is Chuck Rob Matt
Phil
Bob
Rob
um
yeah Tomcat it's not a name uh all right
foxy and fox
it's also an animal uh that's not a in a
purse okay anyway all right
let's do another one
hey Matt and Chris hello this is Sophia
greetings from Florida she loves her new
show and it comes at a perfect time
because I have a question I need some
advice
um I've been a teacher for the past 12
years working in education and studying
education and at 32 years old I'm
considering a career change something
totally different uh going to
Acupuncture school and getting my
acupuncture license and starting the
practice in eastern medicine cool so I'm
feeling a little bit of guilt around it
because I know that I'm a good teacher
and I feel like maybe I'm letting the
kids down or
that I'm wasting the money that I put
into uh going to school to get my
masters and all the time spent just
studying education so yeah let me know
what you guys think I would love to hear
your advice thank you so much love you
guys bye go into thank you very much go
into do what you got to do the kids are
going to sniff it out if you don't love
what you do and you want to do something
else the kids are going to sniff it out
you're going to ruin their lives here's
the thing you do love teaching but you
really are being called by acupuncture
you gotta go with the acupuncture you
gotta go where the heart's calling you
you gotta go you gotta leave the kids
they'll find who cares they don't even
remember you you know I mean like I'm
sorry I'm sorry when they're adults they
don't even remember you uh do you
remember your teacher very few of them
yeah me too very few of them well also
how young I remember Miss Harlem who was
in first grade I didn't have her first
grade no no she was white would you have
her first first grade first curations
you thought Harlem looks like Miss
Gilbert no so you remember her and I had
Miss Caldwell was second grade yeah
Miss Caldwell was black was called it
was black oh yeah okay oh miss Natco was
white did you get mad Miss Naco don't
even know who that is right then it was
Ben axis so Caldwell when I moved to
California it was Finn and it was Carrie
then it was cheovich and seventh grade
all my teachers were named tall and I
had I had uh Miss Harlem Mrs Beady Ms
binoxes Mrs
I think I have Mrs Beady again and then
Mrs uh
uh that was when I I came through strong
with missposito that was uh fifth grade
what about did you call her
um
yeah but you remember Mrs Beatty Mrs
baby me off no that's oh would get me
do you call her that now no I never
could have thought of that nope it's not
good to do
oh we're gonna get restricted for that
but that's cool so no no no no okay so I
think that I think that um
remember your members Antoine Miss
Antoine was Kindergarten now yeah I know
that's what I'm saying so so long ago
the kids are going to remember you and
that's fine I see what you're saying
yeah but you got to do what you want to
do the heart wants what the heart wants
right that's what Matt used to say all
the time and I do you yelled at me for
it yeah no but I only said it once you
said a bunch of times and I feel like
you you want to do your uh acupuncture
try at least try to do your acupuncture
do it at least do a little bit of it
maybe you don't like it can always come
back to teaching you come back to
teaching or just do it on the side do a
little hustle right you did a little
acupuncture just start walking down the
streets just start poking people you
know see what happens be like poke and
be like what are you doing and be like
well does your leg feel good okay like
that and they're like
why'd you put my neck he's like I'm an
occupied I've been trying to be an
acupuncture how do you like feeling it's
felt fine I'm like then there you go I
helped you it wasn't hurting your first
place
but yeah yeah honestly acupuncture 2
also has helped me a lot really people
think of it as sort of a pseudoscience
quack thing yeah
whatever you make of it you know but I
swear that I fall into these really deep
like trance like sleeps when I nominal
oil
under the needles and it feels super
restorative and I feel better afterwards
and it's just like full no Matt you
can't just do that so much on the
podcast again people are gonna be like
what is this weird [ __ ] I'll tell them
it's like an extension of me when I used
to when I used to say things and go
afterwards to be cute okay yeah so
nobody's feelings got hurt now I instead
of doing that I say okay I understand
all right well you said the audience did
not they don't okay so next one
mm-hmm
so close I'm a big fan of everything you
guys do I was wondering what is the best
way to tell your girlfriend that you
don't want to backpack through Europe
even though that's something she really
wants to do oh my god dude people who
want to backpack through Europe are so
[ __ ] annoying dude they're so
annoying yeah I just you know what I
want to do I just want to take a year
off to go backpack through Europe you
know what I want to find they always
want to I want to find myself dude
you're right [ __ ] there [ __ ] and
here's the deal it's so annoying because
you're like you think you're doing
something and finding yourself but
really everyone's just waiting around
for you to get back you're ruining
everyone else's life they're just like
where the [ __ ] is Betty hurry up back
you're getting all dirty outside wow
were you in a hostel
well I'm making people worry your
parents are worrying go to college it's
not like okay I mean
if you don't want to go
just say that chicks always want to do
stuff too they're always just like let's
restore an old car and then you're like
really you're like and then like a week
later you're like we've been thinking
about that car thing and they're like
what do you mean and you're like you
want a backpack through Europe with
somebody who does that kind of [ __ ] well
maybe this let's give this woman the
benefit of the doubt I won't and I'll
tell you why I won't because you're
gonna get out there and be like oh my
God it's actually so wet out here then
they can go back and he'd be happy yeah
but then he [ __ ] wasted all the money
just flying all the way over to Europe
dude uh and he's got a backpack full of
shitty kid where his contacts are gonna
wear glasses because he's got to save
space in his backpack can't put contacts
in there all right
you know
but it's just like I think just straight
up tell her be like that doesn't really
sound that great to me and then here's
why
and then just be real with her like drop
all the truths on her because she's
obviously not thinking about the bad
things she's just thinking about how
romantic she's romantic she's
romanticizing yeah sure they're gonna be
hostile
yeah you know what this is a look at
this documentary right yeah dude
everyone romanticizes everything
especially chicks and they're just dudes
do it too but women will be like I mean
that's why they watch the lifetime of
the Hallmark movies they want that love
it doesn't even exist I'll watch those
two though I watch them too but it's
just like they they think like oh I love
those Lifetime movies because the
couples always start out hating each
other for no reason you know right yeah
they're just like Ugh
oh my God look at here's Dan Dan is such
a he's my he's my enemy he's terrible he
just got here and Dan shows up and he's
like hi yeah and I'm like why would you
hate this guy yeah I I love the ones
that are like Thrillers like like the
bad surrogate yeah like the mom's worst
nightmare you know a father's revenge or
whatever it is hell yeah you're always I
like the Love Story it's always good
really like the Happy ones yeah because
yeah I do that's more Hallmark they make
me feel real nice yeah I like the
Hallmark ones I I do like that but no
dude lifetime does like the Christmas
ones and [ __ ] yeah our friend directs
them dude
lifetime ones uh maybe just Hallmark I
don't know I thought Hallmark it's the
same thing really honestly I know I know
lifetime is more salacious but I'm just
saying it's pretty much the same style
of things yeah right budget wise and
it's just like okay so all right yeah
don't go dude always don't go
backpacking through Europe
I don't even like when people bring
backpacks anywhere unless you're
traveling they don't mean like on the
through the mountains they mean like
going from City to city on the Euro rail
I know I know but the real way to do it
is through hot with hostels and [ __ ] and
like yes yeah yes that's just annoying I
mean it's called a hospital if you're 20
it's kind of like an adventure I get it
but like if you don't want to go just be
straight up with her
or she's going to be so annoying and
she's like I'm gonna go then by myself
and then he's got to worry about her
[ __ ] safety you know just some chick
backpacking around like you know you
Yugoslavia
and yugoslavians are just like that hey
what's up girl and you're afraid of her
being alone out there
get a ticket as well yeah in case she
really is dedicated to going then when
it's time to go to the airport you're
like are you ready to go and then she's
like oh I thought I was gonna get a car
you're driving me and then you can just
be like no I'm going with you baby
be the hero of all heroes
what are you doing oh boy
I'm going with you baby
dude I think that uh that's you know
that's annoying that she wants to go
backpacking isn't that funny when
somebody that you're with wants to do
something you don't want to do it's like
all of a sudden you got to deal with
this [ __ ] now like you have a blister
you're just like all right I guess I
gotta wait this [ __ ] out yeah that's you
know what I mean all right let me let me
just let wait till they stop bucking
yeah jeez yeah
well it's a cancer no I'm depressed new
next one and now a word from our sponsor
better Help Therapy has saved my life to
save the lives of many people that I
know that are close to me it is
something that I have always said
everyone needs
betterhelp is the way to go it's the
easiest way to go uh life it just does
not come with a user manual so when it's
not working it's normal to feel stuck
it's normal to feel like you're in a rut
but better help really can help as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched three million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's actually affordable
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it could not be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhealth.com
Lifeline that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash lifeline
you know what we're going to take a
little break to talk to the audience
about talk to you guys about diet smoke
yeah personalize it we gotta be like you
guys not the audience without you guys
y'all I'm gonna talk to you all about
that smoke if you love THC like I do
then you will love diet smoke quite like
I do I've used a ton of their stuff
recently and I do very much love it all
of diet smokes products all of diet
smokes products are guaranteed to give
you the beautiful Buzz you've been
looking for no prescription required no
awkward conversations no sketchy weed
deals you don't even need to go to a
store you just decide you want THC and
they ship it right to your door I've
done it it's amazing and all their stuff
is always good Olive diet smokes
products are made from American grown
hemp meaning they're all federally legal
and each product has a lab test result
for potency and safety you can't get
better than that they got the blackberry
and apple cider flavors right these are
the new ones they released the new ones
yeah try those and you guys y'all gotta
try them I never tasted Edibles as good
as this uh which is the truth and I am
edible King baby uh one last thing just
one little last little detail you're
going to want to keep in mind they
guarantee 100 satisfaction or your money
is refunded you literally cannot miss
with diet smoke so if you're ready for
that perfect high head over to
dietsmoke.com and use code Lifeline for
your 20 off of your entire order you got
to be 21 and older to order
back to the show
next one
hey Chris and Matt love you guys love
the podcast time to get right into it
um I am home alone for three days with
my one-year-old son my husband's out of
town
um here's what just happened it's pitch
black outside and a stranger a man who
I've never met or seen before
comes up to my front door and rings the
doorbell at the time I'm putting my son
down for bed and so I answer on the
intercom like hey how can I help you and
he tells me he wants to talk about the
gospel
it's pitch black like my camera needs to
use the night vision to see him right
very creepy he has two children with him
which makes it a little less creepy both
less and more but why are you here like
do you think that was legitimate
um I also don't have a gun
should I get one is kind of my question
like should I have done something
different
um should I call the church and complain
thoughts ideas
well how would you have handled this
this guy's a woman home alone with these
religious people they don't live in the
real [ __ ] world dude yeah you don't
knock on a door late at night where a
woman's gonna answer when she's alone
and you got kids with you you don't live
in the real [ __ ] world like there's
there's so many other ways to share the
word nowadays
while she's putting her daughter to bed
like what are you thinking I want to
talk to you about the gospel no no dude
I don't care how religious you are you
don't want that
no that's [ __ ] psychotic with kids
I've never even heard of that yeah
that's weird they were just like this
yes we'd like to talk to you about the
gospel they wanted to go home dude he's
like I'd like to read from a scripture
for you I don't have light she's like
and the kid's like I'll get it
light at the Bible yeah beaming it
yeah and that was when Jesus said unto
you do unto the most unto with the river
of John wow unto River unto Rivers
they're always doing on twos and stuff
okay and Jesus said unto his gospel unto
you thy with unto Rule and unto always
have faith in yours
okay the River Jordan oh my God then
they'll just throw in the River Jordan
or some [ __ ] okay well and he paddled
for six years straight you know listen
you're that's what it'll be like
unconscionably loud yeah you know what I
mean right it's like but the Bible will
just be like and he fasted for six weeks
yeah and you're like he would be dead
but he didn't die because he was he did
it for his brother and then his brother
[ __ ] brutally murdered him well
that's not exactly the story but okay it
might as well be dude it's an allegory
what I'm doing okay okay
are you done yeah okay uh so we want to
go next one I guess so I mean I'm just
saying it was you know we were having
fun with the
with the religion stuff did we give her
any advice did we give her advice don't
oh the simplest advice is do not enter
the door don't answer that you did it
you you got through it this is what you
did you did the right thing but honestly
if you're gonna get a gun get one of
those [ __ ] shoulder Predator guns to
where it's just like this and he goes
[Music]
oh
yeah
those are good and then if he said
something go
right right those are good those would
be good dude you just said I'd like to
talk to you about the gospel
I'd like to talk to you about the gospel
it's like this okay
what's that the light oh right right and
then just and then when you lock the
target
[Laughter]
right yeah and then the kid and then the
kids take to go like this oh no what
happened
the face you make when you do that is so
ugly well it's really wild you got it
got you know you gotta keep it real man
it's a real wild how much is what I just
did something that Robin Williams did on
the set of bicentennials oh my God
I did it hey hey and then the Predator
comes and he says
oh I'm a hot dog
I'm a hot dog is the best dude
wow
um do you know what's weird I brought up
by Centennial man yesterday
she knows too much
um dude so fire on fire
[Laughter]
dude Bicentennial Man really
all right
sounds good my babies
yeah I'm gonna be so [ __ ] bad oh yeah
oh yeah the post you're satisfied we
gave her advice Drew from Nashville
Tennessee
you guys have your own show together
finally because
when Matt would be on congratulations
for the past couple years and the
brothers would be riffing it was just
the best so you guys have just this
thank you dude honestly an unmatched
conversational chemistry and it's
awesome so what a nice guy how about you
guys have your own thing now just
gushing I could ask you a question I
have a a friend who's probably on the
scale of zero being complete stranger to
10 being just like would lay down my
life for you probably like uh uh six to
seven okay out of ten friends pretty
good
um and I want to know how do you tell
this person a friendship of that value
that kind of like relational Equity that
they have horrible horrible breath right
it stinks quite literally to stand near
them when you guys are having a
conversation yeah
um
again I don't know how to handle it like
it's got to be handled delicately and I
just don't have the words
um or the approach and I think spin
moves would probably give it away that
would probably be out on this one but
what do you guys think be curious to
know
um honestly that's I can't think of
something worse than bad breath
what about stabbing a lot of stabbing
nah I mean you know with of that level
that's the worst one
stabbing is obviously way worse because
of how it's
so stabbing's worse yeah but that's not
a whole different level oh okay
um I think honestly that is horrible uh
I knew a guy who had bad breath for
years and I was like do I say something
or not and then all of a sudden it went
away you know that could be a number of
things that isn't is an actual breath
like uh Eating Disorders it happens to a
lot of women yeah and the halitosis
which is what it's called crying bad
breath okay well not everybody knows
um but yeah you get uh
you just have like if you're uh not not
anorexic what's the other bulimic uh
trust me if you're bulimic that happens
like
I've been around women who are bulimic
but I didn't know they were bulimic
until this happened oh it is bad bro it
is like rat poison bad oh Jesus yeah
dude you
you kiss them and you're like I just
took a sip of rat poison it's all is all
you can think of you know no I don't
like that at all no it's so bad I don't
like hearing about it it's so bad you're
like you it's like you're trying to kiss
and not make a big deal out of it you've
already you've already exhaled which was
too much like even exhaling you could
taste and smell it
yeah something's that bad you can sense
it well you just actually have to hold
your breath entirely you can't even
breathe out yeah
and I would have passed out if I smelled
that [ __ ] breath too many times too
yeah I mean you can the only thing I
think you can do is be like yo here you
wanna gum I got gum but dude you know
gum doesn't even penetrate that well it
might if you're just standing next to
someone also sometimes I think that
people's uh smells
affect different people differently
there he is what's that he's he's right
right folks for the first time he's
right about something biological no
that's not the first time I'm right
about
congrats dude that's not the first time
block is right twice a day good job dude
good boy okay okay now good boy here's
the deal here's the deal
uh what I the reason why I believe that
is because
these people with bad breath that you
smell bad breath all the time they you
they have wives sometimes exactly what's
going on there so what I also though the
way I arrived at this was this one woman
who I very briefly dated had this in
particularly bad and I I was like so bad
at tiptoeing around and trying to gain
information about what other men might
have thought about her breath wow yeah
how would you even do that really oh God
I don't know number but yeah you can't
do it without being obvious no so I was
being obvious but she never picked up on
it she was so oblivious to it what would
you say what I realized is nobody's ever
thought that about her really nobody's
ever told her she had bad breath and I
was like how many guys have you dated
she's obviously many she's in her 20s
but like I'm slow slower but yeah but
just like she's not what do you mean am
I like it's like you're in a Twilight
Zone you're just like wait no I smell
that it makes me want to die instead of
living I'd rather be dying when I smell
this [ __ ] breath so so what how is
the way you tiptoe around it can you
even try to do that yeah I guess let me
think I mean even not you don't even
have to like think about what you did
say oh it would be like I would tell me
make up a story about how like I was on
a first date and like oh my God I was so
embarrassed my breath was so bad and uh
oh right something like that you know
did you think that do you think that
that ever happened to you did they ever
say no it'd be like have you ever like
you know not realized it but like had
like the
worst [ __ ] breath momentarily or
whatever and she was just like no no I
can't really oh really yeah I can't
really think of one yeah we should have
done when she did that and she was
talking to you guys
no you just go like this oh really yeah
you've never had that I know I did you I
dated a girl that had really
I had to I didn't even let it get far
because I was like oh you can't I was
gonna be like this every time you can't
okay that was the weird thing though it
wasn't every time with this girl so
sometimes I'd be like oh it's gone it
was some like thing so hopefully yeah
uh and then have you had the opposite to
where like the taste is amazing
you're like oh this is amazing what are
you Powerade of someone's mouth yeah
dude it's just unreal no no are you what
are you Fierce flavor Powerade
disgusting no no I'm saying because they
take because they it's like their mouth
is just this beautiful experience I know
what you're saying with the words
no I'm saying oh oh hey nice to meet you
Powerade
oh
to like because you're drinking her in
oh I get it I fully understand it uh I'm
just I just happen to be utterly
discussed one time
a woman tastes so good that I I was
doing that and kissing her and you know
dated her for a while that she was like
what how come you like because I was
just like I don't know like really into
it and she was just like why you know
why is it so much and I was like I just
love the way it taste
and that person was Kristen
I want to throw up and I'm married to
her now so I want to throw up
and hearing that it was Christian
actually made me want to throw up a
little less I'm just kidding I'm the
whole thing a little less maybe you want
to throw it or am I okay anyway
it's bad situation dude I don't even
know what to tell you yeah dude just
gotta bring it up though you got to
bring it up you ever you smell
somebody's breath and you're just like
almost you you feel yourself going like
oh yeah totally right and then you step
outside your body sometimes it's that
bad like Italian people shooting arrows
[ __ ] studies that like when you put
somebody in a room
okay they the controllers you put people
in a room with no neutral smelling room
and you give people something to argue
about like you get a Democrat and a
republican in a room and like test like
their how much you make them talk about
politics right and then you do the same
exact thing but the room has this
intensely bad smell of garbage or
whatever and the people in the room that
smells like garbage are like 800 percent
more likely to get into a physical
altercation than the people that are in
the neutral smelling room dude it what
it does to our brains is hectic Way
Beyond what we even realize we are so
much more irritable it even shows up in
brain scans like brain activity is like
you're like you're just set off alarm
Bells when something smells who set
these [ __ ] these tests up you know I
don't know what let's do the garbage one
come on smell bad what a badass get a
[ __ ] guy who's a Republican and a
democrat in here and ask him about
abortion but get all those [ __ ]
disgusting trash wheel it in yeah go
yeah
yeah I don't know it's you kind of
reverse engineer the controls of the
experiments there yeah okay you don't
know [ __ ] all right well let's go to the
next you literally don't know [ __ ] no
okay that's not true all right guys how
are you doing in heaven we've seen them
decorate them
first of all what has he said the whole
time first of all third of all he's in
heaven he's in heaven yeah he's
literally driving to heaven right now
yeah
so what do you do if you killed heaven
and uh you only have him you're taking a
one-on-one to Heaven All right so we'll
go ahead guys how you doing from the UK
I have a question for you guys I want to
paint them decorating film and my job is
basically
going to decide to make a joke but he's
doing what they should be doing and have
a materials and they need to do their
job
um but sometimes it just feels so
[ __ ] stressful if my car for photos
but
I feel Under Pressure all the time
I feel like I get any breathing room and
uh I know you have a child Chris I have
to right but I don't have an extra
levels of pressure and my wife will say
to me well you need to take time off so
I take time off but I'm going to take
time off what to come off when I go back
I have more words
just Bust Around the question to you
guys is how do you guys deal with the
stress pressures of your life and is
there any advice that you could give me
that maybe would help me in my situation
and I'm not going to do a sign off
what what dude no you did it for
funniness
you did it for fun he just said so
here's my question hit you with what
you're saying someone delay you know
it's silhouette Miller with Emilio
that's Buster Rhymes dude Chris what
what was the gist of it
he has depression
he has a lot on his plate work-wise and
he's got two kids
heard that part and he wants to know
what you do to uh deal with the pressure
of work and Life all at once uh honestly
and this is such a stupid answer I know
but because it works I'm just gonna say
it
10 minutes
daily
jerk sesh it's jerk session no daily
meditation just 10 minutes just [ __ ]
make yourself do it uh find everybody
has time for 10 minutes a day it's
nothing do it in your car do it on the
subway if you're in a city doing in the
bus doing the car do it right after you
wake up do it right before you go to bed
it doesn't matter just do it commit to
it and I know it sounds ridiculous in
the first few times you'll be like this
isn't working just do it for a couple
weeks okay
first time I did it was actually crazy
you felt good yeah I did that's what I'm
saying first time that's what I'm saying
but you're saying you need to do it a
couple weeks but I didn't sometimes you
don't need to yeah sometimes it works
right away
as it did for you yeah it felt really
good I did it again it's like it stopped
I stopped I only did it one time why it
didn't make me come so stupid dude wow I
want to break your neck I'm kidding dude
I know but I still want to break your
neck slit your throat okay and just
watch and like giggle while your blood
like pours out of your neck and I'm
smiling
the meme of the dude yeah yeah yeah
um I can't believe that guy was saying
bully dude that guy was Mr Bean okay
great cool thanks for the question if
that was a question but yeah the advice
uh is get some uh
it's a the fact that that was his
question and he had paint all over him
too just made it like so real oh he's a
painter I forgot he said that he did say
that okay yeah God bless the dude I feel
like uh I don't know man meditation is a
good thing I would say try meditation I
tried it once and it worked nice
anything that you can do to Center
yourself because what's happening is
your brain is swirling and I've said
this before on the show I think but like
anxiety is actually something that is
good for us it's what motivates us it's
what makes us do things makes us
competitive makes us excel at things
but in certain brains anxiety runs a
muck and it's beyond the point that it's
useful it's past the Tipping Point so
you're suddenly just like [ __ ]
overly anxious when you have no reason
to be it there's no help to you so just
be aware of that and once it's passing
that level just be like no anxiety
anxiety listen to me no
stop
roll over a woman's defense class no do
you stop do you end it
zebras don't get ulcers
is that code
zebras don't get ulcers
zebras don't get ulcers because uh they
don't have anxiety yeah dude but it's
not just zebras and I wanna I know
specify the animals I'm saying yeah us
as humans there's too much going on we
have too much stress we get ulcers
zebras don't get ulcers it's what
separated us evolutionarily from back in
the day from zebras it made us smarter
to be able to worry and plan ahead
and talking it made us think uh anxiety
nervous about what was going to kill us
what we were going to kill there you go
where are we going to camp out for that
night uh we have to be able to talk
that's right these things led to us
being as smart and advanced as we can as
we are but it's been since things got a
little easier post-industrial Evolution
things are a little bit easy and now we
have all these [ __ ] therapists and
problems in our lives because we
overthink stuff
we have a low-grade anxiety at least all
the time because we're worried about
things like phone bills right but zeros
do not worry about things like phone
bills all they do is just absolutely
chillax the whole time they lick each
other they drink water from the lake the
only time they have an endralin spike is
when they see that hot as [ __ ] big lion
that is when they do it I'll get it once
they run away and then they're just
chillaxing again dude they look at each
other when they're drinking zebras right
now look what I figured all this I'm
saying oh because I said to think about
how zubas don't get ulcers but I know
but before that why are you thinking
about
zebras
I saw a a YouTube video about a zebra
earlier today because Calvin was
watching a cartoon zebra thing and what
did the zebra do therapy
what did the zebra do what was the video
yeah the zebra was just like walking
around and Kelly kept being like zebra
zebra zebras are cool so I'm saying I
know that I saw that video it had
nothing to do with this but because I
saw the zebra now I'm using it and I
know the animals don't get all sorts of
sorts of zebras don't get ulcers because
the more specific you are the funnier
you are and I'll tell you one thing I
know comedy congratulations I believe
you funny you say that because that's my
podcast well anyway plugging yourself
okay so one more or more more than one
more what do we think okay yeah you know
what
me and my girlfriend recently moved into
this apartment with our girlfriend Aspen
and our neighbors above who've been here
for a while have a pitbull uh we're
sitting outside when their dog came down
the stairs and attacked our dog and my
girlfriend
ripped up my dog's nose pretty bad we
ultimately told our landlord about this
situation just to keep him informed and
he told them that they have to leave
immediately or get rid of the dung so
now we're stuck feeling some of this
guilt about the situation
um like it could have been prevented and
like ultimately some of it's our fault
when really it wasn't
uh just wondering how we can alleviate
some of that tension in the household
um and ultimately just make ourselves
feel a little bit better about the
situation so yeah big fan of the show uh
thanks in advance see ya what a nice guy
nice guy it's not your fault at all no
yeah like if your dog bites the [ __ ] out
of another dog's face you got to get rid
of that I gotta get rid of the dog yeah
but it could have been a human it could
have been a baby understandably feels
bad because he has a dog that he loves
any other person who doesn't want the
other person to have their dog taken
away but it's like then move then I
understand right right right but like
you can't live in a place where you have
a dog that would do something like that
you can't so you gotta move there's no
reason to feel bad that person has to
move right that's not acceptable like
you can't maybe he just feels bad that
he has to the guy has to move sorry dude
but he has to move even before the
attack I'll tell you something my dog
bites his hair another dog my dog take a
hike I live where I live
and I'm very compassionate okay yeah but
also it's different because you would
never get a dog that would attack no I
wouldn't but that's but you don't know I
don't know you do he said it's a pitbull
I'm sorry look I love pitbulls I know
but people are going to get a lot of
trouble they are
very very let's say
if you were to train dogs to fight
pitbulls would take to that much quicker
than other dogs they have a higher
amount of aggression
and if you want to focus on that in the
in your training of them you can turn
them specifically them into killing more
than other dogs into animals that kill
uh and a lot of people do do that with
my Yorkies too I just need more Yorkies
it's hard to get those qualities out of
the dogs unless you have them from a
very early age if you have them since
they're a puppy it's just like any other
dog yeah you know you get 50 Yorkies
though
okay get up all right all of them [ __ ]
oh no no no no no they finally knock you
down whoa [ __ ] that's it's knock you
down while that happened I Said Knock
You down that would be like uh which is
amazing
a nightmare you know what just like
someone you know but some of you are
still some of them are still kind of
licking you and stuff oh no no you're
not all bad I gotta go get a thing it's
fine leave it okay leave it leave it
okay sorry
let's put a little bit better yeah
they don't know they're sleeping uh all
right um wait what was the advice get uh
I think I said get 40 Yorkies no oh yeah
no dude don't don't feel bad you didn't
do anything yeah that person
unfortunately should not be living in a
building that's not how it works you
can't you need to be responsible as a
dog owner and if you have any dog
pitbull or or whatever any kind of dog
it doesn't matter there are plenty of
other dogs that are vicious and and mean
and aggressive that would do that would
have done that to your dog and if an
owner has a dog like that they can't be
living in an apartment building that
where there are people with dogs it also
is not responsible of the person you're
also a good guy and that's great you're
a good guy which means you're a good guy
all the time but you're good guying at a
time you don't need to be good guy you
don't need to be at all right so it's
just sad it's a sad situation it's like
someone getting you know HIV that's what
they get there's nothing you could do
about it what you can't do nothing you
can do about it but why is it like HIV
because there's nothing you can do about
it you just got to be like okay this is
not my fault of all things to bring up
did he give him HIV who that guy gave
who HIV he didn't give anybody HIV sure
100 and that's why he did he could have
he said he said girlfriend maybe he's a
girlfriend HIV or somebody you can he's
walking around with shots
if you're heterosexual you know about
that joke when the two guys are in the
elevator and the one guy's like you got
to give me all your money or I'll inject
you with HIV and the guy says no he says
you sure you want HIV and he says I
don't care inject me with the with the
with this with the HIV and he says okay
fine then you should just give me your
money he's like no I need injects him
anyway he says jokes on you I'm on a
condom
[Laughter]
that was a good joke it's an old joke I
heard it once I mean I don't know if
it's kind of like on
I don't do jokes it's kind of like on
it's uncouth yeah yeah you know well
yeah I mean not really living on the
edge is it I don't know I don't like
jokes though I don't like jokes either
they all seem uncouth to me is what I'm
saying well they're in bad taste jokes
it's just like what are you what is it
1912 yeah I don't like it either yeah
and that's how people are always like
when people say like oh Crystal it
doesn't even have punch lines it's like
I don't know the [ __ ] punchlines man by
Design yeah yeah yeah what do I have
[ __ ] dork dude but also honestly
steeper you know it is deeper but also
about you no I don't give a [ __ ] about
that man I like to go out there and have
a [ __ ] good time now yeah do I cry on
stage sometimes of course you know when
I get deep but like you know
come on out to see me by the way I'll be
in New York soon chrysalia.com and also
Seattle from Portland on my tour don't
push me or I'll cry in parentheses um
yeah dude all right let's do one more
one more yeah one more one more Barbies
yo yo hi Matt hi Chris my name is also
Matt I'm a huge fan
um
of Chris son of a [ __ ] but um
I kind of wanted some advice
I'm a shitty person
basically
well the reason I think I'm a shitty
person is some girl today in my class so
from New Jersey
basically related a poem you're reading
to
her friend dying of cancer so
basically what I'm trying to ask is am I
a shitty person for being easily annoyed
and irritated by people who kind of like
trauma dump onto not strangers but
basically strangers in like a college
class for example does that make me a
shitty person
um because I think it might but
let me know what you guys think
um again big fan life rips
hope you guys see this thanks dude you
yeah so hold on in her class she gave up
she was told she wrote a poem where she
found a poem they were reading a poem
and some girl in the class uh related it
to
her friend dying of cancer and he's
irritated by that I mean irritate
irritated is one thing if you're [ __ ]
going on and on you can't [ __ ] think
about it anything else and you're pissed
off that then yeah but you're not a bad
guy I mean you're asking the question
here yeah so the fact that you're asking
the question means that you at least are
you know looking inward you know what I
I I just got lost in thought thinking
about something
I don't like when people ask if they're
a piece of [ __ ] or a bad person like
what what do we know
you're you you know like you ask
yourself that and then act accordingly
if you are a piece of [ __ ] try to be
less of a piece of [ __ ] but like if you
have to ask somebody else I don't even
like buy the question you know what you
think
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah uh also
like
don't be so hard on yourself if it
[ __ ] bothers you it bothers you you
don't need to carry it with you it
doesn't matter yeah I mean people get
there to you and then you move on so
you're not a piece of [ __ ] like you're
not a bad person unless you it's you
can't be a bad person based on the
things you think you can only be a bad
person based on the things you've
actually actually do uh or ways you
behave in the world you know uh I'm just
gonna say that okay sometimes sometimes
things you say too depending upon what
they are that the threshold is obviously
higher for them but still it's like you
you don't buy the brain that you have
you only have it so if that's just gonna
annoy you there's no way to make it stop
annoying you so just be like ah that
annoys me and just put it to bed right
there move on with your day you forgot
it by the end of the day
you get mad at me when I clap at my own
advice
I do it now when it's good all right
well all I'm saying is I had for you
earlier dude come on yeah you did but
you when you clapped you said I'm
finally right about one thing so it's
kind of dick right right yeah that's
true
um yeah are you a bad person you're not
a bad person you know but like no you
I'm sure you weren't like [ __ ] stupid
friend yeah you internalized it you're
just like oh you're like whatever it's
all good and uh you know I was pissed
off the other day at something going on
I can't remember what it was it was like
it was a few weeks ago and uh I was like
I was with a table of people and I was
like I'm so mad right now because of it
and they're like and I was like why am I
so mad and they were like it's okay that
you're so mad you just you're not saying
anything and doing anything shitty yeah
so it's fine I was like so I just
exactly I just said mad and they were
like yeah she's like okay but once you
realize that it passes so much quicker
it passed I don't know if it would have
been quicker or not but you know how mad
were you maniac I was Blazing mad it was
something with a waiter I can't remember
what it was I can't even remember
anymore it was nine points it was nine
uh there's nine people table
uh oh they forgot my food and they
didn't do it right yeah
and then they had to redo it and then
they redid it wrong when I said it right
in the first place ah you know what it
was he was one of those waiters that
came by and was like what would you guys
like and you're just waiting for them to
get out the thing to write it down and
they don't do it and then they [ __ ] it
up and they forgot my [ __ ] and it's like
dude I'm not impressed I'd rather you
just write it down all the time
and always get it right then not write
it down and get it wrong even once for
somebody moreover here's the list of
things that would impress me but uh if
you're my waiter here's a list of things
you ready absolutely zero things true
the only things that you can do as a
waiter is [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up and if you
don't [ __ ] up you're an amazing waiter
yep [ __ ] up you're not a good waiter
yeah dude it's like why don't you just
try [ __ ] unicycling over like oh wow
I don't give a [ __ ] much matter I
know exactly balance it on their nose
who would care just don't give us what
matters can I take your order hi can I
take your order yeah oh wow oh we don't
care I'm not a Cuda dude just bring the
[ __ ] salmon in that [ __ ] Carnival
dude just give me they're spinning the
plates on their fingers don't care don't
care put it down and here's the other
thing too when they say [ __ ] like oh uh
you know what would you like and you say
it and you're just watching them listen
and they listen and they repeat it back
to you and you're like okay yeah I guess
you got it and they're like great
I don't want to have to be like great
just write it down go get the food bring
it back and let me eat my salmon dude
write it down why are you not writing it
down
because they want it it's like a classy
place it's like a nice place it also
wasn't that classy of a place it was
attached to a [ __ ] Hilton for [ __ ]
sake why is it classy to to not have to
write something down that's not classic
because they want people to be like wow
they didn't even write it down oh oh
dirty notebook whatever the [ __ ] they
don't even thinks who thinks wow is my
point nobody nobody nobody the owners
owners show me love up in the club lost
your mind no nobody nobody nobody
you actually seen a way to write it down
you're like ew yeah I mean who gives a
[ __ ] dude it's gonna be right I wanted
to write it down a matter of fact maybe
it's because they don't want them to be
uh
uh that you could always blame it on the
well sorry we don't write you down so I
[ __ ] it up because they write it down
and [ __ ] it up what does that deserve
well that means everybody in the back
[ __ ]
wow
what is this it's the Gatling
the Predator has that no well he has one
that just kind of just but I made it a
Gatling one like such a nerd why you
said that you know but yeah I made it
again it makes me laugh because it's
actually just makes me laugh because he
doesn't have a Gatling gun but but I
installed one in my fictitious worlds
right yeah it's a crossover it's a Delia
uh Predator crossover okay
yeah that's clear versus Predator so
stupid
uh oh we're done dude I love how they
make those movies Aliens versus Predator
and [ __ ] and it's just like it's not
aliens it's alien versus Alien versus
Predator yeah I know but I'm just saying
they should do one that's like you know
another one oh wow [ __ ] trailed off
at the end so much
it's AVP dude I only universities
in [ __ ] Freddy versus uh Jason Freddy
versus Jason yeah the mashup movies yeah
are never good dude no just never good
they should do one uh Alien versus
Sylvester Stallone from Copland
wow
there you are also he's deaf in that
movie you know play with that yeah
I can't okay you coming and I can't see
it because you're invisible wow good
impression you're doing some good ones
today
what's that
oh
and then this is over worst sounds of
all time all right everybody thank you
we love you one-on-one advice sessions
with me your boy Matt
delia.com every time you see on that
website is Pacific Standard time so what
you're gonna do is remember that and not
not remember that thank you you go to
watch lifeline.com to uh if you have a
question you can get the merch at
lifelinemerch.com you can also get this
fantastic shirt this afternoon is
absolutely butter soft at chrisley.com
and then also you can uh go on to uh my
website chrisley.com and get them
buttersoft tickets to the road man I'm
gonna be in you know New York Seattle
Portland San Diego
thanks guys
[Music]